[Musica]
che ci accompagna
considerato un esperto di tecnologia ma
quello che mi ha sempre affascinato
della tecnologia e l'aspetto umano cioè
come impatta poi sulle nostre vite non
sono un uomo di prodotto non sono
ingegneri mi occupo di capire perché ci
può servire
quindi vi voglio parlare di due
strumenti che sono rivoluzionari sono
quello della realtà aumentata è quello
della realtà virtuale
spesso si confondono in verità sono due
cose molto diverse
la realtà aumentata è quella che c'è è
sparita anche la realtà aumentata quello
che ci consente di vedere
sostanzialmente quello che mi circonda
con più dati con un aumento di visione
quindi posso vedervi attraverso un
telefonino uno schermo di un telefonino
o anche attraverso un visore collegato a
un computer la realtà virtuale invece
qualcosa di molto diverso indossando
queste tecnologie attraverso un
telefonino in un visore o attraverso un
computer e un visore potrei lasciare
cortina ed essere dappertutto
capite bene che queste tecnologie quindi
hanno una portata molto grande e molto
importante ho bisogno del video qui sul
palco per cortesia
la cosa che interessante da dire è che
nonostante mi sia occupato di tecnologia
per tanti anni in verità la realtà
virtuale
mi è stata presentata da una start up di
ragazzi molto giovani che si occupano di
arte perché la verità è che la prima
fonte di ispirazione della realtà
virtuale è forse la prima il primo caso
di realtà virtuale e proprio l'arte
perché quello che noi vediamo non è la
realtà non è una fotografia quando si
tratta di pittura di scultura ma
un'interpretazione dell'artista e quindi
questa tecnologia porta con sé una dote
importante che quella appunto del mondo
artistico quello che ho fatto
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo e occuparmi di
capire questo fenomeno perché il
problema di quando ci sono nuove
tecnologie capire se poi veramente
lasceranno
io mi ricordo quando iniziato a lavorare
in internet nel 97 lavorava nella prima
azienda televisiva in italia mi
prendevano in giro quando ho iniziato a
scrivermi un secondo libro sull'e
commerce mi prendevano in giro e mi
trovo in una situazione molto simile
dove molti amici colleghi e ancora non
capiscono la portata di questa
rivoluzionaria tecnologia quindi ho
fatto un lavoro veramente profondo che
fanno
ho lavorato tra l'italia e gli stati
uniti ho intervistato aziende manager
imprenditori che hanno lavorato in
questo settore dalla a di arte alla v di
viaggi e sostanzialmente vedete non ci
sono settori che rimangono fuori da
questa tecnologia
poi vi spiego perché però provate a
immaginare come potrete comprare casa
domani entrando in una casa che di
solito comprate su una cartina o su
delle foto ma sarete dentro la casa
vedrete la differenza che c'è tra stare
all'ultimo piano o al primo piano con
un'esposizione a nord oa sud
potete decidere l'arredamento di
qualcosa che ancora non esiste
tutte queste applicazioni sono già
disponibili oggi tante aziende anche in
italia già qualche anno fa hanno
iniziato investire in queste tecnologie
con grande risultato non lo urlano non
lo gridano perché hanno un vantaggio
competitivo che non è banale
quindi tutte queste tecnologie sono
pronte per essere adattate a questo
sistema abbiamo parlato anche di sport
in questa giornata molti atleti hanno un
training attraverso la realtà virtuale
quello che però vi dicevo io non sono un
uomo di prodotto non sono un ingegnere e
non sono venuto qui a raccontarvi come
funziona questa tecnologia ha dovuto
scrivere un libro e porta via e mezza
giornata quindi quello che voglio
raccontarvi è perché vi dovrebbe
interessare questa tecnologia
ce n'è tanta si parla di tutto aiuti
block chain
ma questa è quella che impatterà più
nelle vostre vite quotidiane è sicuro è
quello che voglio fare
non voglio parlarvi della tecnologia ma
voglio arrivarci facendo un punto della
situazione
né su quello che guida il nostro animo
quello che ci fa crescere ci fa sognare
sono le arti emozioni le esperienze la
visione è anche sostanzialmente i media
che sono diventati sempre più liquidi
sempre più diffusi tutti quanti noi
abbiamo un telefonino con questo
passiamo buona parte della nostra
giornata
perché queste tecnologie hanno
importanza beh per arrivare al punto è
il tè dx da questo punto di vista
un'esperienza straordinaria perché io ho
dodici minuti di tempo controllati al
centesimo per passarvi un'idea
importante da condividere con voi e devo
arrivare quindi al punto non posso
girarci intorno è il punto magari voi
non lo vedete ma io sono su un punto
rosso e c'è una differenza enorme
permetterà avere visto centinaia di ted
comodamente a casa in ufficio
spaparanzato e rilassato è essere qui
con voi in questo momento emozionato a
raccontarvi questa storia tra essere a
casa e essere qui c'è una bella
differenza
perché questo è fondamentale perché
queste tecnologie indossando la
tecnologia entrate in quello che è un
mondo digitale che finora è fatto di
faccine di foto di video ma entrerete
nei contenuti
cambia tutto perché tutti sarete sul
palco tutti vivrete l'emozione di fare
qualcosa che non avete magari mai fatto
quindi per arrivare un po al punto dal
mio punto di vista la riva la
rivoluzione digitale solo da internet in
avanti ha fatto veramente qualcosa per
noi come individui come persone prima si
è trattato di un evoluzione della
rivoluzione industriale
abbiamo sempre fatto di più sempre
meglio in meno tempo spendendo di
bravissimi contente le aziende gli
azionisti ma noi come persone
abbiamo avuto veramente qualcosa in
cambio della tecnologia
secondo me poco forse un po di comunità
tante informazioni certo ma la
rivoluzione secondo me deve venire
perché la rivoluzione c'è quando diventa
una rivoluzione culturale
e quindi il percorso che voglio fare con
voi è basato di tre su tre tappe le
esperienze le storie e quella che io
chiamo media reality questo unione di
due tecniche aumentata e virtuale di una
realtà digitale le esperienze sono alla
base della nostra vita ciascuno di una
delle passioni
io sono un'accanita motociclista giro il
mondo e cerco di non fermarmi mai imparo
ogni volta
conosco territori persone luoghi che non
potrai conoscere starmene stando
ovviamente tranquillo sul divano non
sono l'unico evidentemente se noi
riuscissimo ad alzare gli occhi al cielo
vedere quanti aerei ci sono ce ne sono 5
mila in qualunque momento della giornata
ci sono 5 mila aerei che si muovono
questo sembra un quadro una riproduzione
di quanti aerei si sono spostati in un
giorno negli stati uniti sotto dicembre
11.000 voli sono partiti 114 mila sono
atterrati c'è un po di gente che viaggia
e cosa fanno queste persone cercano
esperienze quello che ti può dare un
viaggio e sul mondo di internet cosa
succede beh come potete immaginare
succede molto di più un po la comodità
ma un po anche il fatto che la
tecnologia chi abilità fare molto di più
in un minuto ci sono 4 milioni di
ricerche su google non sono passivi
questi stanno cercando qualcosa non
stanno guardando fotine ci sono 4
milioni di persone che stanno guardando
video su youtube in un minuto e in un
minuto più o meno si collegano un
milione di persone su su su youtube
scusate su facebook vengono caricate 9
milioni e di foto al giorno su instagram
stiamo vivendo e condividendo il mondo è
infatti dietro il successo di realtà
come qui cito ad esempio airbnb ma
potrebbe anche essere il caso di amazon
e di tanti altri non è solo il prezzo a
guidare il successo di un'azienda
digitale ma la sua capacità di creare
nuove esperienze
le esperienze sono alla base del
successo al giorno d'oggi
il sistema economico che ha basato sulle
experience design
se pensate a apple apple ha sempre
pensato prima a disegnare l'esperienza
del prodotto poi il prodotto che cosa ci
faccio come lo uso quando perché la
customer experience è uno dei tipi a e
di qualunque azienda si parla di
marketing esperienziale l'arte è passata
ad essere scultura pittura a essere
astratta a essere concettuale a essere
che cammini sull'acqua sul lago d'iseo
l'anno scorso sta diventando qualcosa di
più la nostra vita siamo sempre più
votati alle esperienze perché perché
culturalmente e qui io ho avuto la
fortuna di lavorare sempre con ragazzi
molto giovani a 50 anni ero il più
vecchio all'interno di yahoo al mondo
quindi capite quanto l'azienda fosse
giovane i giovani hanno rivoluzionato il
modo in cui noi concepiamo lo status
sociale e il nostro modo di vivere una
volta io studiavo all'università la
differenza tra avere o essere adesso qui
la nuova generazione lavora e pensa
sempre nel fare le cose e nel
condividerle
quindi noi siamo le nostre esperienze
non è una novità lo dicevano già gli
antichi greci e le esperienze sono
nostre sono qualcosa che facciamo noi
come il bambino che masticava il cubo di
legno
le storie sono un'altra cosa perché le
storie sono le storie altrui
noi viviamo in un mondo che è immerso di
storie ci alziamo la mattina sentendo il
telegiornale sentiamo vediamo come vanno
le cose sul lavoro tutto il giorno
chiamiamola mamma la moglie per avere le
storie della giornata loro e concludiamo
magari leggendo un romanzo e sognando
qualcosa siamo sempre mezzo le storie il
motivo è che abbiamo bisogno delle
storie perché le storie ci fanno
immaginare perché se noi basassimo tutto
sulla nostra esperienza sarebbe
oggettivamente un problema perché non
impareremo mai nulla e quindi einstein
diceva che da una parte si la conoscenza
deriva dall'esperienza
ma attenzione che se non hai
nazione non ti muoverai mai nel caso mio
ad esempio dal punto rosso quindi le
storie sono importanti però sono le
storie degli altri e questo ci apre
sostanzialmente ad avere un altro punto
di vista
questo è un punto secondo me chiave
rivoluzionario delle tecnologie di cui
sono ormai esperto cioè il fatto di
mettervi nelle condizioni di vedere
altri punti di vista perché noi siamo
abituati ad avere sempre solo il nostro
quindi questa immagine è un giochino che
faccio spesso perché a seconda da dove
vi ponete è oggettivamente tre oggetti
diversi qual è quello giusto sapete la
novità nessuno perché non esiste una
verità assoluta
dipende sempre da tutta una serie di
fattori quindi se io vi dico pensate la
gioconda tutti pensate a questo quadro
ma ce ne sono decine nei musei
ci sono riproduzioni molto diverse la
gioconda era una persona quella di
leonardo è una sua visione ma la
gioconda era tutt'altro
o meglio era una persona con con diverse
sfaccettature quindi le storie sono le
nuove esperienze che ci aiutano a
migliorare con le persone e arrivo al
punto della tecnologia perché ed è
questo e tecnologia ma anche esperienza
e design e dal punto vista
dell'esperienza io da piccolo sognavo di
fare l'astronauta gero strano che tutti
giocavano a condire cowboy quindi c'era
un filone già scritto
si sapeva che c'erano gli indiani ti
spara vi qualcuno moriva fare
l'astronauta erano appena andati sulla
luna non sapevi neanche come boe al
giorno d'oggi potete provare
quest'esperienza con qualunque visore ed
è la bbc che ci ha dato questo strumento
l'opportunità di trovarvi nello spazio a
gravità zero
stando a casina uscendo di casa questa
tecnologia sta entrando lo sappiamo nei
musei e vito quello che già sapete ma
sta entrando nelle scuole nelle
università nelle elementari nelle medie
perché questi strumenti consentono ai
bambini di imparare molto più
velocemente
apple in questo caso prima google
tutte queste aziende che producono
questi contenuti anche dal punto di
vista dei film e delle esperienze stanno
lavorando su un vecchio detto che va
bene nel caso mio tradire il fare mia
mamma diceva c'è di mezzo il mare quando
io dicevo sì sì sto facendo ma non avevo
fatto è la verità è che se ascolto
dimentico se leggo ricordo ma l'unico
modo per capire le cose e farle
e questa è quello per cui le grandi
aziende della silicon valley stanno
investendo capitali enormi perché questo
non riguarda solo i bambini spostiamoci
su di noi fare dei corsi di formazione
su attività pericolose o attività di day
by day con un realismo totale è un
enorme rivoluzione perché potete farla
più spesso ha un impatto sul conto
economico importante e le persone hanno
modo di imparare molto più velocemente
quindi nel caso della formazione ma nel
caso ad esempio anche della medicina
siamo di fronte a una rivoluzione
pazzesca perché finora qualunque medico
lavora su foto su immagini su qualcosa
di piatto in questo momento i medici
stanno entrando nei nostri esami
la differenza tra vedere una foto ed
entrare in un organo dove magari la
mattina dopo andrea operare capite bene
che dal punto di vista del valore per
noi come persone inestimabile
tenete conto che dopo l'area
dell'entertainment l'area che investirà
di più è proprio quella del led che dopo
di che ci sono tutta una serie di altre
aziende di altre aree dall'automobilismo
tutto quello che riguarda il mondo della
della cultura ma anche quello che
riguarda ad esempio il settore
dell'industria quindi non è una
rivoluzione che fa solo divertire e
sorridere e provare nuove emozioni ma ci
apre a dei nuovi mondi a cui di solito
siamo abituati a star fuori dietro uno
schermo dietro magari anche uno schermo
molto piccolo vi cito questo esempio per
poi chiudere il caso della più grande
raccolta di beneficenza che mai stata
l'ha fatta dalle nazioni unite in
svizzera i grandi economisti si trovano
al world marketing forum
queste persone hanno indossato una
tecnologia di realtà virtuale hanno
vissuto l'esperienza di cosa significa
essere dei bambini in un campo profughi
in cisgiordania quindi i bambini siriani
è stata la raccolta di fondi più
importante della loro storia c'è una
bella differenza tra vedere la foto di
un bambino leggere la sua storia e
finire con lui di fianco e vivere 19
minuti di esperienza quindi capite che
la potenza della tecnologia come sempre
è tutto e niente dipende dal contenuto
dipende da come sappiamo utilizzarla noi
siamo comunque ormai perché queste
tecnologie sono già qui entrati in una
nuova alba tecnologica che si basa sulle
esperienze che si basa sulle storie e
quindi qualcosa che ci dà più conoscenza
più immaginazione e un mondo che direi
non ha più confini per certi versi e
quindi il senso del mio intervento e
darvi un anticipazione di quello che
sarà un nuovo mondo che è già qui che è
un po un isola che non c'è per certi
versi perché è intoccabile ma il posto
della fantasia è il posto dove le cose
cambieranno e noi avremo modo di vivere
nuove esperienze
vi ringrazio
il tuo mondo c'è già la magia
ai grandi la chiamano tecnologia